Music playing
Jason: I had a dream last night that it was the best episode we've ever done.
Jason: So, I couldn't sleep the rest of the night, got in here, fired up the old machine, and I'm now waiting on these guys, and I am loose.
Jason: I got a little bit of a sweat going. The hammies are pliable, flexible, and the jaw muscles are ready to really ask some tough questions and giggle at my funny little friend, Sean and Will.
Jason: Guys, welcome to Smartless.
Intro playing
Sean: Hi, guys.
Jason: Shut up Sean.
Will: Oh my god. I've never I haven't last laughed so hard as I did today Today.
Will: When we were standing on the street.
Will: We'd just come out of a meeting, the three of us.
Adults? Like adults.
And Sean Sean starts to say something, and he like he's doing right now, he he undoes a a top of a bottle of water, he's about to take his hip and or, you know, he's going to do it, and Jason slaps it out of his hand.
Mhmm. Lands on the ground.
And lands on the Just a fun little hair pull.
Yeah. Just a little fun fun Just a plastic bottle.
Nothing broke. Plastic bottle.
So I reached down to grab it because it falls at my feet.
And I hand it to Sean, and as he reaches for it, I just drop it right before he can grab it.
Like, it's Sean, that's twice. That's twice. Then denied water.
And as it lands on the ground, Sean reaches down to get it, and Jason kicks it.
And it goes flying, hits a curb, and goes under a parked, like, construction truck.
It explodes. Top comes flying off. The water's everywhere.
Fucking funny.
Was And I haven't laughed that hard.
I felt the main Because it was It was high school all over again.
It was like It was a little bullying.
We're just You know?
Was just fun and stupid. God, I love it. Fun.
You know? Jay, did you like my cheesecake last night?
Yeah. Cheese now I I would've I would've liked it a little firmer, Sean.
A little Yeah. It was a little too fluffed.
You know, it was a little, it wasn't as gooey as the last one, so I feel like we're we're making progress.
I like the the last one
No. I say this as a person who I can't even boil water.
So the fact that you cook anything is incredible.
It's impressive. But also, I didn't know, Will, either that I didn't I've never made whipped cream in my life.
I didn't know that you just pour half and half or whatever in a bowl And whip it.
And you just start The special whip you just start whipping it.
I was My mind was blown this time.
I was like, oh, is. Do you think it's a good idea that you've now learned how easy it is to make whipped cream?
I think so.
I think so. I think you know what I'm doing tonight.
Yeah. You missed out on a good cheesecake last night.
Well, but then I found out then Sean told me that the secret ingredient that he does drive an hour and a half for.
Yeah.
It was a a British, chocolate, Cadbury white chocolate bar.
No. Not Cadbury. It was another brand. But yeah.
Another brand that we're not gonna mention, I guess.
We can if you want.
It's called Milky Bar.
But we already mentioned Cadbury, so think we're kind of uncommitted.
But there's a there's a is that is that a thing?
Is that normal that there's a white chocolate candy bar in most cheesecakes?
Well, no. No. I just melted it to make kind of like the creamy part part.
It was one of many ingredients. But it was it was, know thought you tuned into Smartless.
It's, it's cookless this week.
Bakeless.
Tasteless.
I I and I I was so obsessed with getting the ingredients right.
I I drove an hour and a half to get it because they don't sell them in The United States.
And what did he do, Will, when he got there?
So you drove to another country.
When he when he drove an hour and a half away to get this what did he do while he was there?
He's like, Well, look, here's a here's a a rare, joint that we don't have near us.
Yeah. Portillo's.
Oh, that's why he Portillo's.
Went Yeah.
And he put a big burger in his face and a and a shake too,
I'll bet.
Yeah. I got a shake, piece of cake, and I got fries and a hot dog.
Wait. You got a shake For lunch?
Piece of cake, fries, a hot dog.
Then a When you were then two running beef your sandwiches.
And what's that? Two beef sandwiches, one
And for this is when you were on the mission Weren't you to pick driving a school bus?
White chocolate.
Yeah. Well, I had I picked up the white chocolate.
Were you buying for all the kids in the school bus?
No. I never get it.
So I bought like a little extra stuff and I put it, I put it in the fridge.
I'll heat it up later.
Good for you.
Thank you. Guys.
Oh my God. Yeah.
Let's get started.